Noah: Hi, my name is Noah. And today's test is called record a goose sighting.
and the slug is U. 0 CI dash RGS.
Noah: And today I'm using a macbook pro.
Noah: and I am using drag. Naturally speaking, I am on a windows, 11 operating system with parallels
Noah: and my task today is I am using this goose citing website to record some answers, change them and just explore the page.
So I'm going to start by hitting the start. Now, Button. there's not much on this page when you're using the speech recognition software like dragon
Noah: buttons that have text on them are very helpful, because I know what words to say when I'm trying to click on the button.
Click, start now.
Noah: Great! And so that worked the way I thought it would. So here I'm going to answer this question. Select if you like, geese
Noah: sure. Click! Yes.
Noah: again, this is perfect. I see the yes button. That's where I want to click. And that command works.
Noah: Click, continue.
Noah: So it's perfect cause we have. Yeah, all the buttons have text, and that's good. So here tell us what type of goose it was, and we have
Noah: a sort of example, a black spur, winged goose, and that's can be helpful, because if I want to click into that text box I should have 2 options. I should be able to click into there by saying, Click, tell us what type of goose it was, and click black spur, winged goose. So I'm gonna try the second option. See what happens.
Noah: Click, black, spur-winged goose.
Noah: click, black
Noah: click goose.
Noah: Okay.
Noah: I would have expected to be able to click in sometimes when you have symbols like the dash doesn't work. But let's see if if the tell us what type of goose it was? Works
Noah: click, tell us what type of goose it was.
Noah: Go to sleep
Noah: great. And so that worked so I would probably in this case not have the grayed out text in there.
Noah:  it's just confusing, because often you are able to say that to click inside. So if you're going to have the text there.
Noah: I would say it's probably I wouldn't use it as an example. If it's an example, I would maybe put the example below the text, box EG. Blacks for winged goose.
Noah:  I would only have text there if you don't have text above because of space issues. Otherwise I would just leave it blank.
Noah: Okay, so here I'll fill in the only type of goose that I know. Wake up
Noah: Canadian goose.
Noah: go to sleep. wake up.
Noah: click, continue.
Noah: undo that
Noah: delete that
Noah: click, continue.
Noah: click, day
Noah: 7.
Noah: Undo that delete that numeral 7 press tab 11, press tab 2023.
Noah: Click. Continue.
Noah: Okay. So here I have a chance to check out my answers before sending my application. So I we do have an extra link here that I'd like to try out. So what happens with my data? So let's see what happens here.
Noah: click, what happens with my data?
Noah: Okay, perfect. So that opens. Let's see if I can close it. Click, what happens with my data? Nice.
Noah: So that works well. So now I'm going to change the type of goose I saw. So we have the word change here.
Noah: Click, change.
Noah: choose to
Noah: click. Tell us what type of goose it was. Black spur, winged goose.
Noah: Click, continue.
Noah: Okay. So here I would expect, because I already filled it in that it wouldn't ask me again. So I would have expected when I said continue, I would just go straight back to the end part that I was at before. But let's just fill this in again.
Noah: Click day numeral, 7, press, tab. 11, press, tab 2023. Click, continue.
Noah: Click, continue.
Noah: Okay? So that so it's recorded, I have my reference number. So let's see if there's any other links here that I can try out. scroll down.
Noah: click, take a look at the answers.
Noah: Good! That works. Scroll down.
Noah: Okay, lots of links here. Click, submit an issue.
Noah: Yeah, I mean, click back.
Noah: I think this is pretty accessible. I think that these links work. There's no, I don't really see much purpose in me clicking through a lot of these links. Let me think.
Noah: I really didn't run into any issues. I think a very mild issue was that grayed out text in the text box that caused a bit of a delay because I had to guess which word to save, to click into the text box. It would have been better if the words were outside the text box.
Noah: That's not really an accessibility issue, more of a usability issue. And we're actually run into any accessibility issues. So that's really well done. So thank you very much. I'm assuming a lot of thought went into creating that and a lot of iterations. And I don't have much in the way of accessibility feedback that I can give to improve it so. Thank you very much.